how did you decide where CinemaCon how
did you decide what footage you wanted
to show today to the theater owners you
know that's something that gets done
super bright by above my head I'm so
focused in creating the film as a whole
that people go we really love this
moment and we want to get that out there
because we think it will kind of help
inform people will engage them with what
kind of movie we've made them and what
we're looking at so someone came to new
that moment I was like that's a great
cinematic moment we're at CinemaCon I
love this it's a exciting engaging
cinematic moment where are you in the
editing process we just looked so music
so we're but it's very tight you know
we're not finished filming that long ago
and you appreciate editing users and
long process so but where they were
locked and you've got a great move your
hands how many songs are actually in the
movie
I think there's gonna be up with the
twins oh wow yeah suggest no me there's
a great scene we're helping this is
playing to a music publisher so these
plays like three in a row
back-to-back other guys getting rubbish
boring play another one that kind of
early early parts of this career but
then this whole whole song Rocket Man is
really long and expensive but it's a
huge musical number and it sound right
but I think it's over to it I think 23
at the last games this is my last thing
for you yeah you have a star that can
actually sing how does that actually
maybe change the way you make a movie
when you can have your lead actor
singing these iconic songs
well we always set out to Myka music and
and and if you can see musical anyway
the actor same people same you guys it's
all age you would expect that to sing we
would have come out of mine but what it
allows me to do with someone like Sarah
knows it's incredible instrument is that
we can have a dramatic scene and shake
right seamlessly into the musical number
because then that son can come out of a
tomato actual movement and he could just
launch into the song and just those
things are pray together which you see
in the film happens quite a lot I use
that very much as people to in dialogue
and then
so for me that was really kinda we
approach it as a musical that we exploit
Aaron and his musical talent and that we
keep the film booming and since they